muy bien ya estamos listos para empezar
a hacer análisis de circuitos y esto es
a lo que queríamos llegar y por lo que
estuvimos aprendiendo todas las leyes
fundamentales pero bueno las leyes
fundamentales son la ley de ohm que nos
dice que el voltaje es igual a la
corriente por la resistencia y luego
también tenemos las leyes de crit hoff
la ley de corrientes de kirchhoff y la
ley de voltajes de kirchhoff ésta nos
dice que la suma de todas las corrientes
en un nodo es igual a cero y la ley de
voltajes nos dice que la suma de todos
los voltajes en un lazo también es igual
a cero ahora la otra ley que tenemos en
realidad no es una ley es una convención
un acuerdo y es la convención de signos
para componentes pasivos que nos dice
que si tenemos un resistor con un
voltaje con su terminal positiva y
negativa de esta forma entonces la
corriente
definimos fluyendo en esta dirección si
es que estas son las herramientas que
tenemos para analizar circuitos y vamos
a analizar este circuito que tenemos por
aquí digamos que esta fuente de voltaje
tiene un voltaje al que vamos a llamar
bs de 15 volts por aquí tenemos un
resistor r1 y vamos a decir que tiene
una resistencia de 4000 oms cada que
ponga una cama refiero a 1000 y
escribimos 4 acá cuando queremos
referirnos a 4000 por aquí
este es el resistor r2 y tiene una
resistencia de 2000
y finalmente tenemos aquí una fuente de
corriente con una intensidad iv s de
3000 amperes que está fluyendo hacia
abajo
el punto del análisis de circuitos es
encontrar todos los voltajes y todas las
corrientes de este circuito utilizando
nuestras leyes fundamentales pero bueno
para hacer esas cosas lo más fácil es
primero ponerle el nombre a los nodos y
le vamos a poner nombres de letras por
ejemplo aquí tenemos este novo al que le
vamos a llamar a es la unión entre el
resistor r1 y la fuente de voltaje bs
por aquí tenemos un nuevo distribuido
estos tres componentes están uniendo en
este punto y a este nodo le vamos a
llamar b y finalmente tenemos el último
nodo por aquí abajo también es un nuevo
distribuido que conecta a la fuente de
voltaje a un resistor y a la fuente de
corriente y a este nodo le vamos a
llamar ce pero también podemos poner
aquí los voltajes a este voltaje en el
resistor r 1
le podemos llamar el voltaje 1 y ponemos
un signo positivo aquí y su negativo por
acá también podemos ponerle nombre al
voltaje de este resistor b2 con signo
positivo aquí y signo negativo acá este
es el voltaje a través del resistor r2
pero hay un detalle muy interesante aquí
y eso es que el voltaje entre el nodo b
y el nodo c es el mismo sin importar por
donde nos vayamos porque él porque es el
voltaje entre el nodo b y el nodo c
entonces éste también es el voltaje por
aquí pero bueno ahora lo que nos falta
es ponerle el nombre a las corrientes
por aquí tenemos una corriente a la que
le vamos a llamar a 1 y esta corriente
va a pasar por el resistor r 1 hay otra
corriente que se va por acá y pasa por
el resistor r 2 y le vamos a llamar la
corriente
y luego hay otra corriente que se va por
aquí y pasa por la fuente de corriente y
ese pero pues ya sabemos cuánto vale esa
corriente esa es y ese que tiene una
intensidad de 3000 jumpers y bueno estas
son todas las corrientes de nuestro
circuito y nada más tenemos dos
corrientes que no conocemos ahora si ya
estamos listos para empezar a calcular
las corrientes y los voltajes de todo
este circuito pero pues no es como que
lo podamos simplemente ver e ir
resolviendo parte por parte lo más
sencillo es hacer una aplicación de las
leyes fundamentales y eso es justo lo
que vamos a hacer ahorita por aquí están
todas nuestras leyes fundamentales y la
técnica es formular y resolver muchas
ecuaciones simultáneas
ecuaciones simultáneas de eso se trata
el análisis de circuitos de formular y
resolver esas ecuaciones simultáneas que
se forman con las leyes fundamentales
así es que observemos el circuito y
escribamos algunas cosas que sabemos que
se cumplen en el circuito por ejemplo
tenemos aquí la ley de ohm y es la
primera que vamos a aplicar a estos dos
resistor es ok porque sabemos que b1 es
igual a y uno por r uno y también
sabemos que b 2 es igual a 2 por r2 este
es un muy buen comienzo ya tenemos dos
ecuaciones y cuántas incógnitas tenemos
bueno pues para empezar sabemos que r 1
son 4000 oms y r 2 son 2000 oms pero
también sabemos que y 1 y 2 b1 y b2 son
incógnitas tenemos cuatro incógnitas y
dos ecuaciones por lo que todavía
tenemos que buscar más ecuaciones aunque
ya vamos a la mitad así es que nos
ponemos otra vez a observar este
circuito necesitamos otras dos
ecuaciones por lo que lo observamos
fijamente y tal vez se nos puede ocurrir
utilizar la ley de voltaje de kirch off
en este lazo ok tenemos este lazo de
aquí
y este va a ser nuestro lazo que vamos a
utilizar en la ley de voltajes de
kirchhoff y ya que tengamos esta
ecuación nos vamos a fijar en este nodo
el nuevo bebé y vamos a escribir la ley
de corrientes de kitshoff pero para este
nodo la ley de corrientes de kirchhoff
estas son las otras dos ecuaciones que
vamos a utilizar así es que empecemos
con la ley de voltajes de kit hoff en
este lazo empecemos por aquí y démosle
la vuelta al lazo en el mismo sentido de
las manecillas del reloj lo primero con
lo que nos encontramos es un aumento de
voltaje de 15 volts nos encontramos con
esta fuente de voltaje de ese entonces
vamos a poner por aquí más bs y luego
nos encontramos con una caída de voltaje
entonces vamos a poner menos de 1 y nos
encontramos en este punto
y el lazo viene por acá y nos
encontramos con esta otra caída de
voltaje de 2 así es que ponemos menos de
2 y llegamos a nuestro punto de inicio
entonces la ley de voltajes de kirchhoff
nos dice que esto tiene que ser igual a
0 un aumento y dos caídas aquí tenemos
el aumento y las dos caídas y ahora para
encontrar la última ecuación nos vamos a
fijar en este nodo de aquí y vamos a
aplicar la ley de corrientes de
kirchhoff por aquí esta corriente y 1
taza por el resistor y sale de este lado
esta es la corriente
1 y por aquí tenemos la misma corriente
que acá
y ese ahora la ley de corrientes de
kirchhoff nos dice que la suma de todas
las corrientes que entran a un nuevo es
igual a la suma de todas las corrientes
que salen de ese nodo entonces nos está
diciendo que a uno que entra al nodo b
es igual a dos
y ese y dos más
y ese que son las corrientes que están
saliendo del nodo entonces ya tenemos
aquí nuestras cuatro ecuaciones
simultáneas y únicamente tenemos que
resolver estas cuatro ecuaciones
simultáneas y así encontramos en
nuestras cuatro incógnitas y esto es lo
que vamos a hacer en el próximo vídeo
tenemos las cuatro ecuaciones
simultáneas y tenemos aquí b 1 y 1 v 2 y
2 b1 y b2 y 1 y 2 y definitivamente
podemos resolver estas cuatro ecuaciones
simultáneas